تويتر العصفور الازرق حتى الان مازال يحلق
في سماء مواقع التواصل برغم من هجره
الرافدين لسياسه الملك الجديد الى مصر
من انتشار خطابات المتشدده مرورا لمعارضه
نموذج الاشتراكات مدفوعه اذن الى اين يلجا
المهاجرون من تويتر وما هو حجم حركه
الهجره هذه
هناك عده بدائل بدات تزدهر في الايام
الاخيره لكن تبدو من الصد سكاي وعاده
للغايه رغم انها نتزال في مرحله التجريبيه
30,000 مشترك انضموا لهذه المنصه خلال
يومين فقط مدفوعين بشغف تجربه شبكه تواصل
جديده بقياده جاك دورسي المؤسس والمدير
التنفيذ السابق تويتر
[موسيقى]
علامه التوثيق الزرقاء كانت اكثر ما اثار
غضب مستخدم تويتر خاصه يستخدمها كل من
يدفع ويحصل هذه العلامه وبالتالي ظهور
حسابات مضلله ووهميه يعني مثيره للقلق هل
يمكن منصه اخرى
اتوقع انه سوف يتم التراجع عن هذه الاليه
لانها ليس لا تضمن بشكل كبير التوثيق
التوثيق يحتاج الى تقنيات اكبر ومعقده
اكثر من تطبيقات وتقنيات البلوكشن وانا
برايي الابحاث ما زالت قائمه بشكل كبير من
اجل تقليل ما يسمى الفايك نيوز او انتشار
الاخبار المضلله وهذا طبعا لحد الان لا
نجدهم 100% بصراحه في ايام منصه همم
وبالتالي همم اذا ان تضبط 100% سوف تعدم
الحريه واذا اردت ان تسمح المجال للحريه
سوف تنتشر الكثير العمل ما زال قائما
والابحاث ما زالت جاريه في صناعه ما يسمى
نيو انترنت بروتوكولز وهذا ما يقوم به
الان جاك دورسي بحيث انه يعني يسمح
بالحريه والسيطره من قبل الافراد على
معلوماتهم وبياناتهم ولكن نحتاج الى صراحه
الى اليات اكبر من اجل السيطره على
المعلومات المضلله ما زالت المجال واسع
للابحاث والتطوير صراحه
الى الماسك كتب في تغريده ودائما تغريدات
سولافه للنظر كتب احب حين يشتكي الناس على
تويتر على تويتر يعني بيكتبوا عن تويتر طب
اليوم بين بلو سكاي تبعت جاك دورسي
المؤسسه السابق وبين بلو بيرد ان صح
التعبير اليوم كيف راح تكون منافسه
التوجه كله من المستقبل نحو الديسون وانا
طبعا تنبات بهذا الموضوع
من العامل الماضي يعني واضح الامور بصراحه
التطورات العالميه تذهب نحو تطبيقات
البلوكشن وتسمح به نوع من الشفافيه لكن
بنفس الوقت عدم التلاعب بالمعلومات
والبيانات وهذا التطبيق وهذا البروتوكول
همم ارى انه سوف ينجح بشكل اكبر لان الناس
خلاص زهقت من من القدس زهقت من الاسلام
والروبوتات التي تنشر المعلومات المضلله
والسيطره المركزيه يعني هذا الشيء همم
اتوقع انه غير مستمر ولا ولا يكون دائم
يعني بصراحه
[موسيقى]